وائل الدحدوح لرصد هذه الغاره التي وقعت
الان والتي تبدو قويه وائل ما المعلومات
هذا صحيح مياده هي واحده من الغارات لكن
الان بدانا نشهد هذا النوع من الغارات
التي تعتبر ربما اقوى من الغارات التي تمت
حتى الان على الاقل في سحابه هذا النهار
هي غاره قويه وشديده
وراينا ان اعمده الدخان المتصاعده منها
احتوت على قدر كبير من الرمال والاتربه
والطين وايضا ربما بعض الامثله الصادره عن
بعض المنشات وبالتالي هذه تعتبر غاره
شديده في منطقه تخوم منطقه جباليا شمال
قطاع غزه وهي ربما قريبه من المناطق التي
استهدفت حتى الان بسلسله من الغارات
الاسرائيليه التي كما قلنا
تحدثنا انها تركز حتى الان على المناطق
الشماليه
لقطاع غزه وابتداء من بيت لاهيا مرورا
وبيت حانون وشرق مدينه غزه وجنوب مدينه
غزه وايضا جنوب قطاع غزه وبالتحديد قباله
منطقتي خان يونس ورفح جنوبي القطاع هذه
الغاره تتويجا لسلسله الغارات التي وقعت
حتى الان وكانت سبقت هذه الغاره غاره اخرى
ولكن استهداف لمجموعه من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين في منطقه رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه
ووزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه تتحدث ان
فوق الان الان
اسقط صواريخ
بوضوح في سماء غزه الان رشقه صاروخيه
شديده كما يبدو وغار اسرائيليه بشكل
متزامن الان في هذه المنطقه يمكن للمصور
ان يوجه عدسه الكاميرا اليها الان في هذه
المنطقه القريبه نسبيا من المكان الذي
نتواجد فيه ولعلها في منطقه النفق في
مدينه غزه
وهذه الغاره ربما بشكل متزامن تماما مع
اطلاق هذه الرشقه الصاروخيه التي تعتبر من
الرشقات
يعني ذات الصواريخ بعيده المدى نسبيا
باعتبار ان شكل هذه الصواريخ وقوه
اندفاعها وحتى ارتفاعها وهي منطلقه من
قطاع غزه تعتبر في مناطق بعيده نسبيا عن
قطاع غزه
ولعلها تستهدف ذات المنطقه وكانه سيناريو
يعني الصواريخ ترد على الطائرات والطائرات
ترد على الصواريخ فيما يتعلق باستهداف
ربما يعني ذات الاهداف هذه الصواريخ
تستهدف في معظمها المناطق الشماليه
الغربيه او على الاقل مما نراه في زاويه
الانطلاق لهذه الصواريخ تنطلق باتجاه
الشمال والشمال الغربي لقطاع غزه في حين
ان الطائرات الاسرائيليه الحربيه تقوم
باستهداف ايضا المناطق الشماليه والشماليه
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه وهو الامر الذي ربما
يعني
يشير بما لا يدعم مجانا للشك بان هذه
الموجه من التصعيد سوف تستمر ويمكن ان
تشهد يعني ربما توسع لرقعه النيران وربما
لغزاره النيران في ضوء هذه التهديدات وفي
ضوء الت التي تصدر عن الفصائل بين الفينه
والاخرى بان هذه المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي
في اطار الرد الطبيعي والمشروع للدفاع عن
الشعب الفلسطيني والرد على عمليه الاغتيال
التي طالت ثلاثه من كبار قاده سرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري
للجهاد الاسلامي اول من امس وبالتالي
الوضع في قطاع غزه ربما يحمل في طياته
خلال الدقائق والساعات القادمه تصعيدا من
نوع ما ولكن سوف نبقى نتابع ونرصد كل هذه
التطورات حتى نقرا من خلال هذه التطورات
الميدانيه وجهه هذا التصعيد ومداهه وما
يمكن ان يتضمنه من يعني احداث وتطورات
ومشاكل ذلك لكن حتى الان كنا نتحدث عن
الغارات الاسرائيليه والغارات الاسرائيليه
التي تتزامن مع اطلاق الرشقات الصاروخيه
وفي احدائها كما تحدثنا في محافظه رفح
تسببت في سقوط شهيدين واصابه ثالثه حسب
المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي ربما
ترتفع حصيله الشهداء منذ موجه هذه التصعيد
منذ حادثه الاغتيال الى تسعه عشر شهيدا
واكثر من او نحو اربعين جريحا وصفت جراح
بعضهم بالحرجه او الخطره حسب المصادر
الطبيه الفلسطينيه وفي حال استمرت هذه
الموجه من التصعيد بالتاكيد سوف تحمل في
طياتها ارتفاعا لمثل هذه الارقام تماما
كما هو الحال بالنسبه لاعداد الصواريخ
التي تطلق من قطاع غزه ردا على هذه
الغارات التي تسقط شهداء وجرحى